hold up that was one shot it hasn't cut
i i love the shot as long as i don't
think about why they're doing it
it's simple visual effects with very
high level concept i almost feel bad
pointing out like a flaw in the shot
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
episode stick around to the end so you
can find out how to get 25 off of each
pair of vessies hey what's up everybody
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react today we're
back to the og couch crew sam me ren
it's gonna be a good time you got some
good clips to look at how you guys doing
i'm alive today that's great wonderful
all right we're kicking off today with
the bang a reverse bang uh we're
watching tennis let's take a look at it
guys have you guys seen tennant yeah
it's the first movie to film everything
completely upside down you're right all
right so since you haven't seen it we're
about to watch a fight scene where we
have the protagonist here that is his
name fighting somebody else who's going
backwards in time i look forward to
hearing you guess how you think they did
these shots
the dude all the armor on is moving
backwards in time according to us since
we are moving forwards in time with the
main character here
can we just watch the movie instead
trust me it doesn't actually really
it's more about the concept than this
about the uh execution story i'm still
looking for the visual effects like i'm
not seeing anything
here's the thing i can't tell if there's
visual effects in some of these shots
screws with your head because you're
expecting either the shot is moving
backwards or forwards and people don't
move naturally in reverse i guess unless
you're really well choreographed so how
do you shoot something like that how
would you do it wren if you're the vfx
supervisor for this extreme
precision choreography to start even if
you're going to be doing a lot of this
stuff with visual effects you can't just
be like oh yeah we'll do it in post like
it still requires very careful
consideration of how you film it
if like i'm going to approach the scene
i am going to reverse shots like i'm
going to specifically design shots that
are meant to be reversed especially like
that like that has to be reversed right
there
you know he's just got heels so strong
he can just pull himself along
christopher nolan really likes to do
things practically in camera in fact
this entire movie has less than 300
visual effects shots peter's spider-man
cake day short has like 150 vfx shots
yeah so he did the half to the effect
shots
of tennant here
but so this fight scene you're right so
like you have one character moving
forward one character moving backwards
and there's certain things that you can
only sell when the motion's flowing
backwards in the very beginning you'll
see this part where the protagonist
stabs the other guy with a knife and
that shot is actually a reverse shot
because they want the masked and armored
character to appear to be moving all
weird and you know so they have to
reverse the footage to get that that
requires john david washington to do his
performance backwards so that when you
reverse it he's moving forwards it does
get wonky and it gets really hard to
think about so for this choreography to
work they actually had to learn how to
move forwards and make it look like
they're moving backwards as well
well that was dope the stunt team
recorded footage themselves and played
it backwards yeah and tried to mime that
sort of look yeah i get that that's
super dope
that's so cool so we talked about moving
forwards and backwards in time but they
can't just simply reverse the footage
doesn't quite have enough pizzazz right
so watch this and tell me like what
stands out to you as being odd about
these shots
you're saying they're running backwards
up the hill because i'm watching the
gravel reverse yeah you can't move like
that in reverse were they on wires
running backwards while maintaining that
forward motion that would be the way to
do it hyper practically or you just cg
in the gravel
normal forward shot yep okay
i can get behind that too because you
know what cg gravel not too hard it's a
bunch of
simple geometry
particle systems i will say the gravel
looks very good it looks very realistic
speaking of cool concepts and not super
complicated visual effects one more shot
to show you guys
cool
so the building gets shot with from two
teams at the same time one team that's
traveling backwards in time with a
rocket launcher and one team that's
traveling and traveling forwards in time
with the rocket launcher oh and that's
the effect i i love the shot as long as
i don't think about why they're doing it
or or anything else related to the story
get that building out of here and then
they were like hold on we're gonna i
have to unblow it up later when we're
going backwards so just make sure you
bring a second rocket launcher for when
we're going backwards in time
wait like let's actually look at the
visual effects happening here though
like the sim for actually blowing up the
building
is really good is it a sim
is it you think they have sims that are
that good these days all right i'm chris
nolan i'm like bren i'm doing all my
shots for real here's my building and i
want you to blow it up
two times and you're like excuse me sir
so it's miniature
but once i've blown it up once how do i
unblow it up i make two buildings that
are identical they're miniatures so you
can control the situation and all that
stuff and you can fill them with all the
types of cool debris that looks great
when blown outwards
and you just zack king your way through
that stuff some jump cuts on the
explosion points so that way people
can't tell
that's it two models film twice the same
angle and they're just cuts from one
model to the other same exact camera but
they just did it in reverse at the same
speed reversing your footage is like the
simplest effect in your like editing
timeline yeah you know you don't need to
learn all the crazy software just go out
there and come up with fun ideas it's
all about the idea fun fact uh we're
taking a look at the stats on youtube
and i'm not gonna tell you how many
people aren't subscribed but i will tell
you that david i know you're not
subscribed so that's the one
subscription that really matters today
my dad is sitting there going wait what
i'm not
dude tell you dad to subscribe david
come on
oh we're taking a look at eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind so
michelle gondry directed this and he's
known for doing a lot of crazy
camera work and combining stuff in
really clever ways i mean basically
christopher nolan got all his
inspiration from his movies and music
videos for real are you actually
i mean it feels like that oh okay
all right we're gonna do one of my
favorite things it's the guessing game
where we watch a crazy shot we try to
guess how it was made then we watched
behind the scenes and see how it's
actually made i have not seen this movie
it's a really good movie all right pulls
up to the front of this market in front
of a black car saratoga market there's a
bunch of ads on the wall a lot of
vaseline on the lens a bunch of food on
the shelves
hold up
he ended up going around that was one
shot it hasn't cut
[Music]
and all the words are gone there's no
numbers or letters anywhere
and now there's nothing in the
storefronts
i love this movie
this movie is evoked sensations and
feelings i never thought i would
experience outside of my own dreams i'm
gonna take a shot as to how i think they
did this sequence so you don't you don't
actually know how they did it not yet
okay i think we basically shot one two
corners of this building and this
telephone boom right there when he runs
right by the telephone pole yeah that's
the hidden cut got it it's to be like
the very sign in the end it wipes by
you'll see the telephone pole kind of
make it disappear
and it's gone
and now we're picking up the shot on the
other side of the building or something
like that or you know basically another
setup they did wait hold up it's the
same location but it's reversed they've
flipped the footage
so and they probably just parted his
hair the other way so that way when they
flip it back oh you're right but the
market sign moves backwards there
backwards all the signs are backwards
you're right they did just flip it man
dude chris nolan like plays his videos
backwards and michelle gandhi just does
a horizontal flip they shot the whole
movie sideways
anyways there's a cg pull and oh yeah
look at that motion blur on that mailbox
and now we just hidden cut back to jim
carrey back in the original location
doing some paint outs here in after
effects and there's storytelling to all
these visual effects here you know
there's like every single thing in the
scene there's a little step happening
that's hitting you subconsciously until
it's no longer subconscious and it's
hitting you right in the face let's see
how it's actually done let's see the
breakdown
camera panned from hell
all right see how close we were show me
a hidden cut should be a hidden cut
there yes flip image
oh the telephone pole we're on the
telephone pole
trying to align
two different moving shots with
independent position and orientation
trying to like
get those to connect
not easy
interesting it's cool seeing like wow
just make these transitions work just
raw brute force image alignment yeah
it's like you're in that's the deep end
where you're like all right take two
handheld pieces of footage here you
gotta connect them you have to you have
to like actually animate this by hand
no one's here to help you anymore kiddo
you're on your own kid
oh so they projected that and cut out
the windows and then you were seeing cgi
through the windows so i would say we
pretty much called it exactly it's very
simple once you break it down in terms
of like the actual digital effects that
are happening simple visual effects with
very high level concept so effects like
this are super inspiring especially like
the way michelle gandhi does him in fact
one of his pieces that really got me
started in visual effects was his music
video for star guitar which is mind
blowing really stream like have you guys
ever seen the star guitar no i haven't
youtube we can't really do music videos
because even like two seconds of audio
like it's our entire like video flag
dude the one time we did a music video
we didn't even share any of the audio
and it was one of the biggest nightmares
we've ever had on the channel we could
just do it for the website just do it
for our website so let's just do that
it's gonna be on our website if you want
to check it out there's a free trial if
you guys enjoy these videos we actually
have extended versions of these visual
effects artists react videos plus a
whole bunch of other great content
quarter digital.com guys it's finally
happened we have run out of things to
talk about
sorry i ruined your earned your moment
you know what we're talking about now we
need some comments we need some
suggestions
we need some suggestions leave a comment
down below recommending what we should
take a look at next we'll take a look
because as i said we've completely run
out of things to talk about
foundation
look this show i haven't seen it because
it's on apple tv plus which i'm still
grappling with as a platform for films
but it appears that some of the best
visual effects artists in the world and
concept artists have worked on it
[Applause]
oh she's a computer
wow this is really well done
that's the shot this shot is over 20
seconds long this is a beefy shot also
notice she pulls off all of her hair
that's in the shot the whole time yeah i
think she's wearing a cap with the hair
so that hair is like a wig that makes it
so that when they do the hair pull off
there's a physical object there with
reference to help blend that transition
i think this is real footage with
cg elements in there like it's not like
oh this the head of her reacting was
done later i think it's a thing where
it's like no she sat there she pretends
to peel away the skin we reveal the cg
model underneath however the one thing
she does really remove is the wig on her
head sam is right that's exactly what
they did
do you have any tokens
tokens sitting around yeah so no i mean
that's exactly what they did they wanted
her to have an actual thing that she can
grip onto and pull off and so there's a
real camera move and that makes the
tracking very tricky here because on top
of tracking the camera they're having to
do object tracking for her for not just
an object but like various parts of her
like her neck getting the neck to line
up properly the chin and the head and
everything the beginning of the shot's
the hardest part when like it just
starts to rip because you still have all
this like actual footage that you have
to deal with like once a lot of the
skins feel the way then you can just
like have your cg elements kind of take
over but yeah like having to like match
move the teeth and the eyes and all that
stuff and the head movements it's the
hardest thing in the world like yeah
that's moving like a car or an object
you know that's one thing but then
suddenly you have a performance here
where you have so many muscles and this
like amorphous blob on our body called
skin and it's like moving in all these
weird directions i almost feel bad
pointing out like a flaw in the shot but
at the end you see the tracking slip
really hard no i see it did you see the
robot neck i did it's like the
attraction is flawless and like i hate i
hate pointing this out because it's such
a great shot but like i see that and i
go oh because i right at the very end i
get in the same situation where you're
like there you're about to wrap the shot
up and then you see a tracking error and
you're just like screw it render like i
need i'm i can't do this anymore
but you know it's like whatever
i mean i honestly did not see that until
you pointed it out yeah because i'm too
busy looking at this ridiculous face
ripping shot yeah cause it's like you
also have to render skin as photoreal as
possible just to have it transition you
have to project your video onto this cg
part of the skin but now suddenly as it
gets pulled away it turns into full cg
and the colors and the lighting have to
match perfectly to the footage yeah
transitions to the real thing it's a
very tricky magic trick that just
happens right there in the middle and
hey to the team that worked on the shot
we're sorry for calling out the next
dumb tracking but you know it's a good
lesson in that you actually don't have
to be 100 perfect you have to put your
attention to where it matters if the
audience is looking at a big gooey
skeleton face going
yeah don't worry about the neck like
seriously that's the thing if an artist
has to spend like two weeks tracking
that it's a waste of their time have
them work on the cool stuff what's up
everybody it's jordan here to talk to
you about our sponsor for today's video
but also my personal favorite shoe brand
bessie we're entering spring showers
right now and la is not built for the
rain so i pull up on hunter street i hop
out of my car ankle deep in water i
pulled up my pant leg walked through the
puddles walk into the doors of corridor
and my feet were completely dry thank
god for bessie's patented dymatex
technology so what are besties besties
are probably one of the most versatile
sneakers i've ever worn there's so many
different styles so many different
colors you can use them for hiking
running going in the snow walking
through puddles walking through the mud
you name it vest has got you you can
even wear them if you're dressing up for
a night out because they're stylish like
that vessies are made from their
patented diamontex material it's a dual
climate knit material that keeps your
feet cool in the summer and warm in the
winter they definitely don't feel like
they should be waterproof but they 100
are and they're vegan so no animals are
harmed in the making of betsies i'm
telling you right now there's not a
climate or situation where you won't
want to be rocking vessies so go grab
yourself a pair right now and you can
get 25 off of each pair bessie.com
corridor crew click that link you won't
be mad say yesi to vessi enjoy your
saturday
this was a great and confusing episode
yeah it was i feel like the theme of
this episode was all about planning you
know going into doing something with a
very good detailed plan that everyone's
on board with my biggest takeaway though
is that i now have to watch tennis and
eternal sunshine you have a really good
list i'm actually kind of excited this
is
anyone watching it backwards dude no
you're breaking my mind again i'm glad
we finally got to look at tennant we've
been waiting to do that one for a while
yeah